[Music]
a lot of people know
tim shriver as a disability rights
activist
the chairman of the special olympics and
the author of the call
to unite i know tim as a brand new
grandfather
we got together and talked about what
it's like to see
his daughter a first-time mother learn
what it means to love and understand
what it means
to feel loved this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
hey tim good to see you nice to see you
simon congratulations on
grandpa hood three grandpahood times
three uh people bore one another with
grand
grandparent stories and they mostly bore
people who don't have grandchildren with
how wonderful it is so i'll try not to
do that
but suffice to say it is indeed a
miracle
and wonderful and i'm very grateful when
i became an uncle
i remember taking my sister aside
and saying i know you're going to be a
good mother
and i just want you to know that i will
undo
all of the great parenting that you will
do
and and for the rest of your life i want
you to just get used to these words
but uncle simon said we could
well you have a little bit of a hint of
what it's like to be a grandfather
already because uh
i i have the same experience i looked at
my daughter just the other day looking
at it i didn't have to say it to her
she's just
obviously going to be such a spectacular
mother and i just can't wait to steal
the kid
and go fishing and get in trouble and
fall on the rocks and do all the
everything wrong it's an expression of
my natural instinct you know
which is much more much more about
mischief and fun and
delight than it is about conformity uh
and therein lies the problem or the
opportunity
it's actually an interesting question
right do you have to be on your best
behavior when you're the parent
and go against your natural inclinations
to ruin another human being whereas when
you're a grandparent
you can be your true self
hopefully by the time you get to be a
grandparent your true self is a better
self than the one you
there we go when you were 25 or 30 which
is when
i started having children confused
messed up
immature and so on so hopefully my true
self is a little bit more polished
but i asked my daughter what do you want
to learn
in the early part of being a mom and you
know what her answer was her answer was
i want to learn
what it takes to make him feel
like he's completely loved well
i think we all kind of hunt around for
trying to figure out how to communicate
to one another what it would feel like
to be completely loved but sometimes we
kind of try to force you know ourselves
to behave a certain way which is of
course
not what children need so anyway i i
think you're right
when we get a little older and we have a
little less responsibility we can be a
little more free but in the end i'm
guessing
that's pretty good source of love too
hold on what she said
is more profound than i think she even
realizes or maybe she does realize
i want to learn whatever it takes to
make
him feel completely loved
and we're living in a world right now
where we're trying to learn what it
takes for me to feel
completely loved and i think we've got
it backwards
like we're all in pursuit of finding
love
rather than in pursuit of how to make
others
feel loved you're right simon you picked
up a very powerful
dimension of both what a wonderful
mother
my daughter rose is going to be but also
how
wise she's become at a relatively young
age i completely agree with you i feel
like
we've become so obsessed with self-help
and self-improvement and
self everything as though
we could find fulfillment by ourselves
yeah it's taken us down
a very dangerous path i i look for
instance at the data
on loneliness you know i think this is
some of the scariest data in our culture
you know there's a lot of bad news out
there this is one piece of it but to me
it's a really important and very very
inspirational piece
you know almost half of americans feel
significant or serious loneliness
wow and this is pretty this is
pre-covered this is pre-covered 46
percent
in the data wow that that's a stunning
number so if you go into a restaurant
look around you half of the people
you're looking at
are lonely and chronically lonely
we've created such a gap between us that
the spirit
among us is so weakened that it doesn't
hold us it doesn't give
people the sense in which they're not
alone to say to someone you're not alone
such a powerful and loving thing to say
as long as
you can convince people that it's true
yeah do you have comparative data of how
it was
in previous days i don't you know we we
know that you know you can you can use
proximate
uh figures on this for instance
indicators on anxiety we have in young
people that have gotten progressively
worse
uh the levels for instance ucla does a
fantastic annual study of college
freshmen
the levels of anxiety in that group are
over 50 these are
you know these are kids theoretically
who've had the breaks right they're in
college they're in an institution of
higher education
over 50 percent of them report severe to
clinical levels of anxiety
and that number has gone up almost every
year for the last i think they've done
the study for about 20 years
these are indications of uh if you if
you ask me a crisis of
us it's not a crisis of me we see all
the political
outcomes we see the division the anger
the hostility the alternate truth worlds
but
to me that's the story of a longer cycle
of breaking down trust and common
meaning that's a really
interesting little insight there which
is the knee-jerk reaction is of course
we see rising rates of anxiety because
look at the world we're living in with
division etc
what you're proposing which i think is
very interesting is that division
in many cases is symptomatic
we see the division because not i feel
anxiety
because the division but rather division
exists because we're also looking only
at ourselves
as you said the steady drum beat of
becoming more and more and more
self-interested
and the result is what we're you know in
part
some of the world we're living in today
you know i've been asking myself the
question
what are the building blocks of trust
get asked this about a relationship
a romantic relationship a familial
relationship a professional one
if you make your list of what it takes
to trust
someone else most of those
qualities are in short supply a sense of
benevolence for instance the researchers
in
business say that you trust a brand when
you believe the brand has
your best interests at heart
how many people how many relationships
do we have
with institutions where we actually
believe the institution
has our best interests at heart a second
building block
is competence is the institution the
other person
competent to care for my my interests a
third building block is the capacity
to overcome conflict trust comes when
after a conflict there's forgiveness and
healing
where is the forgiveness and healing in
our culture
is very difficult to find and very
difficult to practice so i think when
you
when you break down these practices that
lead to trust
guess what you have you have division in
politics
you have people living in alternate
worlds why we don't trust each other we
don't live in the same world
and what happens to me i'm all alone
this goes back to
your discussion with your daughter which
is i want to learn
the word learn yes what it takes to make
my son feel completely loved
and that education includes benevolence
competence and and to learn those skills
and once again it's not what have you
done for me lately but what have i done
for you lately
and to learn arguably maybe the most
difficult one
i sometimes i think the one that's most
missing in our culture
is the capacity to authentically say
you're sorry
and actually also to be forgiven like
you know a lot of us we we've watched
our friends and
our fellow citizens uh have to apologize
for making horrific mistakes
and we've watched the art or the the
practice of the apology
change what do you mean by that well i
think you know a lot of times
we it maybe even a few years ago
when a public figure apologized they
would apologize
by saying something like this i'm sorry
you felt offended
right which is of course no apology
right of course it's a blame
game right now we see people
more honestly i hope saying i've made a
mistake
i ask your forgiveness yeah that's a big
shift in the culture
i think an important one it has come
as a result of us feeling like when
trust is broken
i need a real apology but i don't need
some fake bs
but but you also got to forgive exactly
where's the forgiveness the other side
of the apologies the other person has to
say
i hear you you're okay we'll bet we're
back
and that's where we we seem to be
struggling quite a lot i i agreed and
that goes back to that service component
right
which is i expect the apology for you
but i have no responsibility in
forgiving you
and that's that's just a public flogging
where the the the apology
is simply the modern day equivalent of
putting someone in the stocks
and weaponizing his or her own mistake
as a way of condemning him or her
further and shaming him or her further
which of course leads to retrenchment
anger hostility and then
division i i can't help it because it
keeps going through my head as we keep
talking to quote your uncle
and to adjust for the days which is to
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
which is ask not what someone else can
do for you but what can you do for
someone else
and we have to remember the times in
which he said that which is the height
of the cold war
the the very real threat of nuclear war
and we lived
with existential crisis the question is
an existential crisis is a wonderful way
for people to come together and we see
this after disasters whether it's a
tornado or a hurricane or
you know an earthquake or something
where it doesn't matter what the
politics
are we come together we help each other
and the question is is where is there an
existential crisis
that affects the entire nation that can
unite us
and i don't think we perceive that and
so we start to view each other as the
enemy
i think that's right i mean you know
there there are
external events as you point out that
can help the age-old
lesson here would be find a common enemy
and you can find common purpose
that works okay
it's pretty short-lived if you find a
common enemy
you can usually marshal your forces the
problem is
that creates belonging by exclusion and
by demonization
of some other and the world is just too
gosh darn small
nowadays to allow for
the only way for creating
common purpose to require a common enemy
yeah and you we see this the political
parties i'm you know are pretty good at
this now i don't know if you're on any
mailing list simon but give five bucks
to a you know to a republican and give
five bucks to a democrat any one of them
running for office and you'll be on five
or ten mailing lists
of candidates running for office and if
you read what they say
it's as though both sides are being
written by the same writer you should be
terrified
of this other group they're after you
they want to change your way of life
they are the bad people
we have to destroy them if you don't
give now click here
in order to protect the country you love
they both say the same thing it is
all belonging by demonization belonging
by othering was politics always like
that
maybe it was maybe it was and maybe
religions have always been like that
maybe countries have always been like
that
but here's the thing even if it was
always like that it doesn't work anymore
we have to do what i think
of as create common purpose without a
common enemy
i i've thought about this a lot right i
know i know you have that's why i want
to hear what you have to say about it
well
my conclusions are uncomfortable one of
the things that helped america unite was
the soviet union
and it lasted for a long time when the
soviet union
fell out of the game and we falsely
believed that we had
quote unquote won the cold war we didn't
it they dropped out because they ran out
of the will and resources to play it's
like when circuit city went bankrupt
best buy didn't win anything
same idea all of a sudden we no longer
had an external existential threat
to your point it's much easier to find
belonging
by pointing at what we don't agree with
than trying to talk about we do agree
with because vision
is ethereal right it lives in it
literally lives in our imaginations i
have a dream that's
in our imaginations right and we strive
towards that vision that's the whole
point of vision
but the thing about an enemy is i can
see it and it's tangible and i know i
don't want to be that
and so common enemy is a much easier and
efficient way
to bring people together the idealist in
me hopes that we can come together
based on the dream based on the vision
but the more i
spend time sort of trying to understand
it the more uncomfortable i become that
i actually think you do have to have a
common enemy
and ideally you want that common enemy
to be so far removed that it brings more
people together so the greatest common
enemy
would be a meteor flying towards the
earth
where we don't even debate you know i
mean some would argue that
climate collapse is is that thing except
we're debating it
like we will come together as a human
race a lot quicker
absent that massive external existential
threat
we seek to find the existential threat
somewhere and we find it in each other
where now we live in a world in which
political parties
who simply have different
interpretations on how to advance
towards the vision that is america
that's all it is it's like we think we
should go in this direction we should go
in this direction like
let's take this freeway no let's take
this freeway now we're literally
labeling each other traitors
unpatriotic anti-american like that's
relatively new language for our modern
day i'm going to try to convince you
that your uncomfortable conclusion might
not be
the only one oh i hope so please be the
best one
nothing would make me happier we work in
the field of social emotional learning
and one of the things we've tried to
understand
in this field is how do relationships
function in learning
so you go back to the neuroscience here
and patricia cool at the university of
washington does studies of
infants at nine months 10 months 11
months and into later infancy
and watches the brain and how the brain
develops what sparks the brain
so here's what she found she did a
fascinating little experiment where they
talk 10 to 11 and a half month olds
chinese
so these infants will sit up straight
and they'll listen to a chinese teacher
teach the sounds of chinese and the
intonations of chinese
and then they measure how much the
children these little infants have
learned
then simon they put the exact same
lesson with
a randomly selected control group they
put the exact same lesson on a screen
with the same teacher and then they
measure how much
the infants learn from the exact same
lesson taught
by a human being through a screen and i
want you to guess
at how much what percent of the first
group
is learned by in the second group well
let's take the first group as one let's
say the first group
learns uh one baseline one
yeah okay what do you think the second
group learns as a percentage of one
point five point five zero
zero zero wow
zero uh nothing comes through the screen
now the point is that you know our
religious prophetic
teachers have said things like we are
one we are made for each other
jackie lewis in the book you and i both
contributed to says we are each a house
of god
we hear that language and we a little
bit dismiss it as the language of myth
or magic or the past
but our brain is telling us you are
meant for
another you don't find meaning
unless someone is giving the meaning to
you
in fact you know the way we teach it in
school now
to teachers is teaching and learning is
a relationship it is not
a transaction now why do i bring this up
in the context of
belonging you know there's the old
cherokee story maybe you've heard it so
forgive me if it bores you but the old
cherokee story is the little child who
comes to his elder
i feel like some days i'm uh have
everything i want is good and some days
everything i want is naughty
and the elder says well that's because
you have within you
a good wolf and a bad wolf
and the little child says which one will
win
and the elder answers the one you feed
now
those little infants learning chinese
are having the good wolf
fed right they're connecting to that
teacher they're
feeling the love the desire the hunger
the knowledge of the teacher
and they want to please the teacher i
don't mean that they don't have a
selfish side they do
even at nine months 10 months we have
the same little bad wolf
if we only feed the bad wolf i think
right now
our bad wolf is fully fed and lying in
the corner burping
and the good wolf is emaciated i believe
that culturally we need voices and
strategies and
problem solvers who don't try to solve
the problem as an
us versus them but try to solve problems
as just us
you're right it's more difficult it
requires more creativity it requires
more
outside-the-box thinking in some ways it
requires a whole new mindset
and you may say well good luck with that
tim
and you're probably right that it may be
a fool's errand
but to me it's the necessary errand to
feed the good wolf
and to trust that we actually do hunger
a good
part of us hungers for that oneness
togetherness
without making someone else the enemy we
want to belong but we don't have to hate
to belong
there's such an irony to this in this
modern day and age
where we are steadily losing the skills
to have relationships and we could argue
that the reason politics
are the way they are today is because
the politicians have lost the skills on
how to
have relationships how to reach a cross
now and say how are you
that uh businesses have lost the skill
of how to build relationships which is
why so many people are sort of cynical
towards business and
the number of quote-unquote trusted
brands is precious few and we're feeling
lonely and anxious not because other
people have not learned the skill of
relationships but we haven't learned the
skill
of relationships the irony is is the
first step of our 12
step program is to admit that we have a
problem and that to solve our problem
i'll sign up for an online course on how
to have relationships
well yeah or at least to have the skills
and the orientation and the desire
but this but this goes back to you your
infants are trying to learn chinese
which is so well intended
we're attempting to learn a skill from a
place that we're less likely to learn it
and the place we're going to learn it
it's going to be more difficult it feels
more difficult but the place to learn it
is in our relationships
i want to go back to a point you just
made about politicians we don't see them
modeling the skills we don't see the
media
modeling the skills you know you've seen
the data where
the more time you spend on cable news
the more unhappy you are
not the more well informed you are maybe
you are not the more
politically active you are maybe you are
but the more unhappy you are
why these people have i sadly and i
as you have many friends in the media
who have uh have confirmed this for me
they are uh gasoline on the fire yeah
of course and they didn't start it i
don't think they started it
but they're benefiting from it they're
actually
profiting from division and hatred i
mean you and i are in complete lockstep
and this is something i've been
preaching from the stage for years now
which is there's an entire section of
the bookshop
called self-help but there's no section
in the bookshop called help others
the self-help industry has done one
thing which has helped itself
if it were successful it would be an
industry in decline but it's
shown exponential growth since it was
introduced in the 1970s where
the help others industry that's i want
to build the help others industry that's
what i've sort of devoted
my life to do we need this outpouring of
empathy jose andres in the book
the call to unite speaks of this sort of
several others
the age-old wisdom that when you give
yourself away you get your best
self in return it takes a little effort
i was with a group of high school
students yesterday in salt lake city who
are volunteers for special olympics
and they're on what we call unified
teams in schools which is really just
if you will a classroom of common
purpose right so these are
16 17 year old kids and one kid who's
the star of the lacrosse team
and who's been playing on the team with
his classmate who has
quite significant intellectual
disabilities quite difficult speaking
and so on
and they're sitting on the podium
together speaking to us and
and he he turned at one point in the
commentary and said you know
this is just really all about overcoming
the fear of difference
and then he said you know it takes a
little extra effort
yeah and i think that's the point you
make simon so often
you know the help other section
requires us to stretch a muscle it
requires a little more
work yeah but boy the benefit is so big
and i've talked about this in previous
episodes i always find it funny when you
talk to sort of
people who who have the best
relationships the best marriages
and you take them aside and say what's
what's your secret and they go
yeah it's a lot of work every day it's a
lot of work and like
you know like the people who have the
happiest relationships they don't talk
about how
easy it is they talk about the work that
it requires and i think
we've become a little lazier because
technology has made everything a little
easier for us you know
we can wi-fi enable our lights so i
don't have to stand up
and walk three feet to hit the switch
it's made us all a little lazy
and if you look at the great movements
and when i explain to people the the law
of diffusion how you get the law of
diffusion to work which is how you get
ideas
to spread and how you make things sticky
you have to require people to put in a
little extra effort
because those who are willing to put in
the little extra effort are the ones you
want to show up first
you know the old story right the guy who
prays for years and years to win the
lottery uh
20 years he's prayed to god i want to
win the lottery please help me win the
lottery i want to win the lottery
and finally at the end of 20 years he
hears a voice and the voice is coming
from god he says you got to buy a ticket
if we want to be happy you got to buy a
ticket you got to check in
got to take a chance and you have to
spend the dollar you can't just sit
there and go
i'm going to work my everything
operationally in my house or i'm going
to work my internet or i'm going to
watch 100 hours of
stream you know series you got to put
yourself out there
happiness doesn't just come knocking at
your door you got to open the door
up i think if we're expecting all this
to be delivered
like a like a good take out meal it
doesn't work that way
the soul is shy it needs a little
encouragement it needs a little support
it needs a little hand holding it needs
a little
work you remind me of an experience i
had in college this is sort of i'm
having a flashback right now
i was involved in student government and
i remember i was hanging out with
friends and friends of friends and
there's this guy mike and he was sitting
on the
on the couch watching tv and he was
complaining about everything that was
wrong with our school you know it
occurred to me and i sort of asked him
like
mike you don't do anything like you're
completely
uninvolved in anything at school
and you sit here and watch tv that's
your thing
and i remember sort of coming to the
realization that we have to earn the
right to complain
i'm not against complaining but we have
to have tried in some small capacity you
do not have to have
exhausted every possibility but you have
to have tried in some
small capacity to help solve the problem
yourself
and now you have the right to complain
yeah
if you vote you have the right to
complain about your government if you
don't vote
you haven't earned the right to complain
right
but i think even more positively can i
say this
you have the right to be happy yeah
uh yeah amen maybe it's not a right but
but i don't think
any of us wants really wants anyone else
to be unhappy
i it is a right it is a right but you've
got to put yourself
in the game you gotta buy a ticket look
at the people we admire look
you know i was reading again some of the
work of desmond tutu the other day
you know and this is a guy i mean if you
look at her picture i mean maybe maybe
this seems uh
uh far away for our audience but a guy
in south africa well into his
uh later years uh maybe a a soldier from
a from a former battle but
google the picture of desmond tutu
you're gonna see somebody with a huge
smile on his face
it's just invariant he's he just laughs
as he moves through life
because why because he's had it easy
heck no because he's been treated
brutally and come through it
yes because he took chances on people
who were
horrible to him and forgave them
with proper record that's what makes him
happy because he knows the pain
and he's transformed it he took the
chance
on the other and said even though
i have every reason to close my door
even though i have every reason to
complain even though i have every reason
to sit on my couch for the rest of my
life
and never do anything for anyone i'm
going to take a chance on people again
that's what gives us happiness we can't
you can't phone it in
you got to take a chance you got to put
yourself in the in the game
so anyway i get a little excited about
this kind of stuff this is victor
frankel stuff right
yeah i mean victor victor frankl who
goes to the concentration camps
during the the holocaust and as a young
psychologist comes to the realization
that all of these people
we are all suffering the exact same fate
and some people have the will to live
and some people don't
and yet we're all suffering the same
thing and he you know comes to this
conclusion that we cannot control the
circumstances around us all that we can
control is our attitude
but he says that the attitude comes from
the desire for meaning right yes it's
it's man's
search for meaning meaning is shared
it's a relational game and it comes back
to where we started this conversation
when you break
the bonds of trust and shared meaning
bad stuff happens in the culture yeah
everywhere everywhere your politics gets
bad your everything gets bad when we
look back at our whole lives and say
okay did i live a life worth living did
my life have meaning
and we start to realize that the times
that we were selfish and self-interested
the answer is no and the times where we
gave
and we thought of others the answer is i
lived a life
worth living this my life has my life
had meaning i mean this whole
conversation
was instigated by your daughter's
magical response to you
i want to learn what it takes to make
another person feel completely loved
can you imagine sitting in a room of
pick an age group
you know and say what is your goal in
life well i want to be happy i want to
find love i want to find passionate work
for every one of us to say i want to
learn whatever skills are required to
make
those around me feel completely loved i
mean
what a first of all it would change the
university system would change the high
school system
it would change the way business looks
it would change the way politics i mean
your daughter is entirely right we have
a responsibility
to have an impact on the lives of the
people around us i'm just feeling
emotional hearing you
mention her as she sits in the in the
room next to me
it makes me both so proud of her and and
love her so much
just to hear you pull from her words and
to see and hear in her words such wisdom
which is which are there for sure
you know what i'm walking away from this
conversation with it's a very simple
lesson our
desire to feel love is innate our desire
to feel belonging is innate
but what is not innate are
the skills to produce love or belonging
that empathy and listening and all of
that we criticize others
when they don't give it to us as if they
lack it as if they lack the innate skill
like you don't do this you don't have
this
and what it is it's your daughter's word
learning it is an education
and like anyone who commits themselves
to a
life of learning you don't take a class
and that's it
you can't take a class on leadership and
you're a leader you can't take a class
on
one class on parenting and you're a
parent you can't take a class on
relationships and you're the perfect
husband or the perfect wife that is it's
a constant constant
education and like a muscle if you don't
flex that muscle atrophy you have to
practice
the skills you're learning of empathy
and listening constantly
what does a doctor do a doctor practices
medicine
what does a lawyer do a lawyer practices
law
what should a uniter do a uniter needs
to practice
every day and this is where you know we
can look at some of the great spiritual
traditions
what did they suggest to people who
wanted to cultivate the soul
daily prayer sometimes four or five six
times a day
and you know the irony the irony is we
are surrounded by people who will help
us learn
so for example if you have a friend
who's fluent in french
and you're just learning french you say
to them i want
to practice my french with you i want
i'm going to speak in french to you
correct me when i get it wrong right we
have the ability to go to
any friend any colleague and say i want
to practice listening i want to practice
empathy i want to practice love i want
to practice selflessness
and would you just correct me when i get
it wrong will you point it out to me
because i'm i'm trying to get better at
this skill
beautiful and the irony is it's like if
we're committed to doing the work and
we're willing to do the work
we are surrounded by people who will
help us learn the skill you put it uh
quite beautifully simon and i i think
this honestly i'm gonna
say something that sounds uh a gran
grandiose maybe
i think this is the work of our time
yeah
i think our planet makes it literally
makes it if we turn a corner and begin
the deliberate conscious creative
collective practice of us i want to
thank you
for joining me on this podcast today but
in reality what i need you to do is
thank rose for me
i will i will i will i will believe me i
will
i can't wait to tell her that uh i had
all my data
prepared for this and i had all my
anecdotes and i had all my
insights from the wise and the and the
holy and the mighty and we spent an hour
talking about her and
and and good that we did yeah
congratulations again on being a grandpa
thanks man i'll talk to you soon
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other